[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, Special Relativity.
So in this section,
we want to look again
at collisions and study
momentum conservation.
And so we have
this scenario here
in which we have two balls
colliding with velocities uA
and uB, mass mA and mB.
And after the collisions
there, the mass
is changed to mC and mD.
And the velocities
are uC and uD.
Momentum conservation
tells you that the product
of the mass and velocities
and the sum of the two
particles before and after
the collisions is the same.
But now what happens if
you boost the system?
If we look at the very
same system with the
boosted reference frame, and we
can just simplify the case here
by just considering
the x direction.
So the question is if
momentum is conserved
in a frame s, like the one we're
looking here in this picture,
is the momentum also conserved
in a moving reference
frame with relative velocity v?
And so you can show this quite
easily, that this is actually
not the case, right?
So you write down
the velocities.
The momentum equation
is the same as before
with boosted velocities.
And you find that
this is not the case.
You can easily show
this by, for example,
setting the right part
of this equation to 0,
and see whether or
not this equation will
hold true in general.
And it doesn't.
But in the last section, we
introduced the new concept
of proper velocity.
So how about redefining
momentum through proper velocity
and just saying mA times
proper velocity A plus mB times
proper velocity B is equal to
mC times proper velocity C,
and so on, and see whether
or not we can learn something
from this equation?
So why don't we write down
this very same equation
and with proper velocity
and see whether or not
it's invariant in the
Lorentz transformation?
OK.
Again, a good moment
to stop the video
and just work out the math
by yourself, on your own.
So I did this here.
And I'm just doing this
for the x component.
So we have our proper
velocity vector,
which is gamma times C, gamma
times uX, gamma times uY,
and sometimes uZ.
And so the x component
is the first component.
And in the boosted
reference frame,
the proper velocity of the x
component in our boosted frame
is gamma times the proper
velocity of the particle
A, first component, minus
beta, upper velocity
of A0's component.
And then you can
write your equation.
And this should be our momentum
energy, momentum conservation
equation.
OK.
And the Lorentz transformation?
We find this one here.
And so all we need
to do now in order
to show that this is always
true, or true in general,
is to reassign, relabel,
reorder the individual terms.
And I did this here
to make this visible.
You see everything behind, in
this bracket behind the beta,
is equal to the equation we
had before with the minus sign
in between, which means it's 0.
And everything we see on the
top of the first component,
it also be 0.
That's for the boosted
reference frame.
So we see here, and it just
shows this for the x component.
You can show this
for all components
that momentum is conserved.